Okay. Well, in this case we're really just picking whether or not the thread is even or odd.
Each warp will have some even threads and some odd threads, so it's a total slowdown of 2.
Here we're doing an integer divide, okay?
So threads 0 through 31, when divided by 32, will return case 0,
and threads 32 through 63 will return this expression, will evaluate to 1.
They'll evaluate case 1 and so forth. So, here we're getting no slowdown at all.
All the threads in a 32-thread warp will still end up taking the same case.
And finally, threadIdx.x/8.
So now there will be 4 different distinct values
that this expression evaluates to for the threads in a warp.
And so we'll end up evaluating cases 0, 1, 2, and 3 in the 1st warp,
4, 5, 6, 7 in the 2nd warp, and so forth.
So this time we'll take a 4x slowdown.